[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
it wasn't the fences
it's not the doors or the locks on the
doors
hell it's not even the 400 [ __ ]
cowards that would go stop that son of a
[ __ ] it
is the [ __ ]
guns
it's the [ __ ] guns
i don't know why we have to keep doing
this over and over and over and over
again
even even as we watch
another [ __ ] gunman walk into a mall
here we go adding more to the [ __ ]
list of places you're not safe in
america because of the guns
of course you the uvalde police failed
there was 400 400 officers on the scene
and not one not one
had the courage to save those children
or attempt
for
77 minutes
and the report is going to blame it on
fences and door locks
i would almost bet that the majority of
americans grew up in schools that had no
fences that worked prisons and the
reason why is because we didn't have
these stupid [ __ ] guns
we had we had we had crazy people we had
people who wanted to seek revenge
for whatever reason but we didn't have
these [ __ ] guns we find out in this
report that this son of a [ __ ] not only
not only because of greg abbott that
[ __ ]
he was able to go buy that gun on credit
without a [ __ ] background check he
never fired a gun in his life
it's the [ __ ]
guns
you stupid [ __ ]
it's not complicated it really isn't
we have a situation in this country
where a person who wants to seek revenge
for whatever reason
can walk into a store
use a piece of plastic to obtain a
weapon of war 1700 rounds
and murder slaughter tear apart 19
children and two teachers in a classroom
that he wants to seek revenge in because
greg abbott greg abbott just has to have
that [ __ ] nra money baby they just
have to have that [ __ ] profit they
gotta have it it's a [ __ ] must in
this country and damn damn any parents
damn any safety damn safety in public
[ __ ] them we want your money we want the
money and we want it now
because don't get twisted that's what
it's all about the money and the fear
the money and the [ __ ] fear
and i appreciate this report in uvalde
it's about goddamn time we come to some
kind of truth because these [ __ ]
parents were lied to [ __ ] lied to
that [ __ ] from the moment it happened
they were lied to
about time we get some goddamn truth but
for them
for for that state ramp to blame it on
fences and doors you sick son of a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
the fences weren't high enough
the fences weren't high enough
how about how about the [ __ ]
background checks weren't [ __ ] good
enough how about the [ __ ] guns are
way too good to murder 19 children how
about that [ __ ]
how about that
i'm gonna keep yelling and screaming
about this [ __ ] issue i got [ __ ]
kids and i know a lot of you out there
have kids and grandkids and these [ __ ]
in these [ __ ] schools and it ain't
defenses it ain't the doors
that's a bunch of
[ __ ] and you [ __ ] know it and
greg abbott [ __ ] knows it ted cruz
[ __ ] knows it and that [ __ ] state
rep that sat and gave that [ __ ]
report knows it ain't no goddamn fences
or [ __ ] doors it's the [ __ ] guns
we watched it in indiana oh well a good
samaritan with a now it's not good guy
with the gun anymore it's good samaritan
with a gun
there wouldn't be an opportunity for a
good samaritan with a gun
to [ __ ] have to take someone out
because we're giving access to guns like
it's goddamn candy
jesus christ a [ __ ] weapon of war has
more goddamn rights in this country than
a woman's uterus
it's ridiculous
we're out of our [ __ ] minds we're out
to lunch this is not this is not okay
this is not [ __ ] normal
and again it's all because of money and
fear that's it money and fear baby
that's what's driving this whole goddamn
slaughtering of america
your children are in danger you're in
danger in public
it's a risk in this country that you
take
to go to a shopping mall to go to a
grocery store to send your kids to
school
to attend a parade it's a risk
because of profits and fear
the fear they want to strike in our
hearts like [ __ ] ronnie jackson you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm gonna rake
that [ __ ] over the coals today
you drunk ass [ __ ]
you and your little [ __ ] little dick
weapons you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] republicans really really need
to get a clue about what tough is
i'm sick of this [ __ ] [ __ ] that
somehow conservatism and fascism is
tough you aren't [ __ ] tough you weak
pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] all you can do is
talk about your goddamn weapons of war
and how those are gonna [ __ ] protect
you you weak [ __ ] you gotta
have guns to protect yourselves
you pieces of [ __ ]
liberalism is the toughness that's the
work in this country that's what gives
us freedom is the [ __ ] work
and the goddamn toughness that we have
with liberalism you pieces of [ __ ]
liberalism is the thing that's hard you
think you think [ __ ] listen to one
[ __ ] to tell you what to do in
an authoritarian state
is [ __ ] toughness that's [ __ ]
weakness you dumb [ __ ]
worshiping at the altar of one orange
[ __ ] that's weakness
getting together trying to [ __ ] form
a government trying to form a democracy
trying to create equality and equity for
all people that's tough
that ain't [ __ ] weakness i'm sick of
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
where this country is turned away from
their [ __ ] roots of freedom and
liberty and liberalism god damn it
that's the toughness
and we need to get [ __ ]
tough it's time it's [ __ ] time gavin
newsom's right fetterman's right tim
ryan's right it's time to get tough on
these [ __ ]
come at them in their faces every day
all day with the politics because
frankly we won't get the policy we want
if we don't win elections
and now's the time for us to [ __ ] win
[ __ ] them
now is the time
you want to change gun policy you want
to make [ __ ] schools safe without
turning them into goddamn prisons you
want to make malls safe restaurants
churches parades it's time to vote these
[ __ ] out send them packing
nothing is [ __ ] [ __ ] get pissed stay
[ __ ] pissed and use that outrage to
go [ __ ] save your goddamn democracy
you can do it it's up to us we the
people the hard work of liberalism a
real [ __ ] democracy oh it's not a
democracy it's a constitutional republic
well stand back and watch
[ __ ]
hide and watch
liberalism is not
weak that's the [ __ ] real toughness
that's what it takes to to deliver
liberty to everyone
not just a certain sect of [ __ ]
people
[ __ ] christian nationalism get the
[ __ ] out of here with that nazi ass [ __ ]
you letting one [ __ ] tell you
what to think and what to [ __ ] do
tell you who the hell you can love and
who you can't
tell you what you want to learn and what
you don't want to learn what you want to
know about history and what you don't
rather you want a [ __ ] band map to
keep people uneducated
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
it's enough enough is enough is enough
of this [ __ ] and america has had enough
of this goddamn [ __ ] enough of it
i know they have
i don't give a [ __ ] where the political
spectrum you stand on you're sick of
this [ __ ] you gotta be
no way you can't be sick of this [ __ ]
so let's use the strategic outrage
and let's win this goddamn midterm and
then after that let's win 2024. who
gives a [ __ ] who's running
stop that stupid [ __ ] too
worrying about who the [ __ ] is running
we aren't even there yet
let these [ __ ] idiots torch this
midterm they're already torching it
dr oz can't even get a word in edgewise
tim ryan is stomping the ever loving
[ __ ] [ __ ]
at a jd vance hand-picked hand-picked
by the [ __ ] cheeto dust mobster and
then he's gonna torch their campaigns
even more by trying to protect his own
[ __ ] criminal ass and announces he's
president we should encourage it
let that [ __ ] run let's do it
let's let's do the georgia runoff again
let's do that
fine by me warnock
slam dunk
on walker
stacey abrams takes the governorship
confined by me let's do that
let him torch this entire [ __ ]
midterm because this week on thursday
we're gonna find out
just what this criminal [ __ ] did or what
he didn't do which is probably more
important
to our democracy
and set up it set us up in a situation
because we didn't pay attention and we
didn't do the work of democracy in 2016
women are losing rights they're coming
after you nationally it ain't a states
rights thing by the way [ __ ] that nope
they're not that they they forgot about
states rights it ain't about states
rights anymore it's about [ __ ]
national abortion ban
next will be a national contraception
ban
next they'll have a [ __ ] sex registry
a when you can and when you can't have
sex they're already they're already
talking about stopping you at [ __ ]
state borders to see where you're
traveling and why you're traveling
these fascists aren't going to stop
people my pro if you're pro-democracy
out there and you want you want the
ability to decide
regardless of what where you stand on
the political spectrum
rather your main concern is bodily
autonomy education health care whatever
the [ __ ] it is
these fascists are not gonna let you
decide
so as long as you still have the vote as
long as you still got it you better go
[ __ ] use it
you give them power you won't have it
very [ __ ] long
fences fences and doors
you you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
gaslighting us in this report that's the
way i see it everyone you know looks at
this report is something great which i
think getting to some of the truth but
gaslighting these [ __ ]
gaslighting these parents gaslighting
texans gaslighting americans that it's
fences and doors
that that's all we need to do is turn
our schools into prisons
because we just can't handle not having
profit from [ __ ] firearms weapons of
war
it's up to you you can make the decision
you still have the choice at this point
this is a choice you still have
and it's not just about texas folks
this cheeto dust confederacy is a
disease and it is spreading
the pandemic that we have in this
country of trumpism is real
and you need to treat it seriously
because it ain't just about their voters
they are infiltrated inside our
governments
inside our courts
inside the state legislators the
national legislators
the [ __ ] law enforcement agencies
jesus you have that [ __ ] mayor in
yuvaldi that [ __ ] [ __ ]
blaming this entire thing on the media
as if the media [ __ ] passed the law
for this kid to get a weapon
as if the media stood back and watched
him murder 19 children and two teachers
in the hallways when they could have
done something about it get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] you weak pieces
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
and that's the same [ __ ] mayor that
told beto to get the hell out of here
this ain't the place for that well now
we know it was the exact place for that
that was the exact place where the lies
were taking place
puking them out of the governor and the
lieutenant governor's mouth
the nra [ __ ] presser that they had
to make sure people oh wow it wasn't
again
it was it was a mental illness which
we're not willing to do anything about
oh and the doors and the fences
and they're still doing it
still doing it
if they took as much time
thinking about [ __ ] who has [ __ ]
weapons and what weapons we have on the
streets that they took measuring the
height of the fence at the school
you stupid [ __ ] idiots
you should be pissed everyone should be
pissed and we should stay pissed
and use the power of our democracy and
our ballot to get rid of these [ __ ]
idiots
that are setting policy inside our
government it's ours it's [ __ ] hours
not theirs
we get to decide
at least for now
so go use the power of the ballot and
i'm not just talking about marking the
ballot
register
talk to your friends your neighbors
show them the way of why this is so
[ __ ] ridiculous
there are people out there that don't
normally vote in a midterm
and they are likely not to vote find
them
talk to them
get in their faces about this
it is an existential threat
and if you don't believe it just look
what happened over the weekend in
indiana
people just trying to buy a shirt
trying to buy a new pair of pants or a
new pair of shoes running for their
lives in a mall
ducking and hiding three people killed
two injured
i think that's the count who knows who
knows
how could you [ __ ] tell anymore
oh well but there there was a good
samara he's not a good guy with a gun
he's a good samaritan now
it's good samaritan with a gun
oh cause that's the answer to see that's
the answer just another gun yep that's
oh that's the answer just get another
gun in there
it's really [ __ ] dumb it's really
[ __ ] stupid
and i can't believe we even have to have
this conversation over and over and over
and over and over and over again
but we're going to keep having the
conversation if you don't do something
about it and i'm not talking about the
politicians folks the politicians we
have the republicans in these states
because let's face it it's not the
democrats
you can yell and scream all you want
that the parties are saying but they're
not that's [ __ ]
give me a [ __ ] break as if democrats
are the ones that are trying to pass
legislation to do away with some apps
gun safety and gun regulation to make
sure [ __ ] guns don't get in the hands
of the wrong [ __ ] people get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ] lying piece of [ __ ] you're
spreading misinformation disinformation
and you're doing the country a
disservice
our democracy you're doing it a
disservice so if you claim to be
pro-democracy and you think both parties
are the same you are not pro-democracy
i'm sorry
turn it off turn me off i don't give a
[ __ ] turn me off if you think both
parties are the same if you're convinced
of that you are not pro-democracy you
are not you're not paying enough a
[ __ ] tension
you're only hearing what you want to
hear
that's it that's all you're doing
they're not the
same the republicans are the ones who
are who are stoking fear and profit for
guns
oh well
just look at just look at the parade
shooting in highland park
some of the heaviest gun regulations
yeah well he bought it legally
he bought it legally because someone who
vouched for him knew he was violent
if we would have better red flag laws he
wouldn't had a [ __ ] gun
in texas this kid never even fired a
[ __ ] weapon before
he went straight to his fourth grade
classroom where his previous teachers
said he was bullied that year in school
it's
the gun
it's the gun he fired a hundred rounds
before the cops even entered the
building
he'd already ripped apart a dozen
children before the cops were even able
to enter the building within two and a
half minutes
folks it's the guns
is what killed those children
and those teachers that's what killed
him that's what the [ __ ]
the 400 cowards were scared of was the
[ __ ] gun
they were scared of the gun
there are no good guys there are no bad
guys there is just [ __ ] guys with
guns and it's the guns dummy it's the
guns it's the guns it's the
[ __ ] guns
and stop saying the two sides both sides
same blah blah blah blah if we do this
if we do that i won't change
these republicans have a stronghold
these fascists have a strong hold on our
state legislators on our governorships
they want to take the congress they want
to take the senate
and it's up to you rather you're going
to allow them to keep pressing these
this [ __ ] fascism on our country
it's enough of this [ __ ]
and yes
the deregulating of guns and allowing
anyone to have guns
and to create chaos and fear is
is the perpetuation of fascism
making women second-class citizens not
just in certain states because they want
an entire cheeto dust confederacy we now
know that
every [ __ ] republican that there is
is walking to the house floor
talking about a national ban on abortion
they can't help themselves it's like
these white men jerk off to women being
second class citizens or some [ __ ]
i told you they would not stop they
won't stop they're not gonna stop
they're not gonna be satisfied with the
amount of fascism they have today
they want more they're [ __ ] greedy
so you need to get greedy
that's right you need to get greedy
about your liberty about your freedom
about your rights
about equality and equity get [ __ ]
greedy [ __ ] them [ __ ] em
it's time we it's time we fight back
in the arena that these republicans want
to fight in these elections
it's it's it's about goddamn time
we have to use the power of our ballots
and again i'm not just talking about
[ __ ] marking your own ballot which is
is fine if that's what you want to do
but you gotta engage in your democracy
to save it
you have to
you have to talk to your friend your
family there are going to be people you
know you love
who want to save their democracy that do
not vote in midterms
find them talk to them
reason with them yeah it's going to be
difficult in some cases and boy you're
going to be super disappointed
about some of the folks you know and
love
that they're just not interested in the
democracy at all they're more worried
about who's going to be playing on
sunday
but don't stop don't get discouraged
it's time now's the time
and let these republicans bury
themselves as we watch dr oz's
campaign in pennsylvania flounder
as we watch herschel walker that dumb
[ __ ] down in georgia sink his
campaign
to save that seat
we can see tim ryan is absolutely
bearing jd vance
who loves to he loves to pretend to be
an elite
but then he doesn't want to be an elite
it's all pretend it's all [ __ ]
now's the time get involved in your
governor's races get involved in your
state senate your state legislative
races
look at the races of the united states
senate
where you can help
if you're not in one of those states
that doesn't mean you can't help those
campaigns
rather it be with a little bit of cash
or a little bit of help on the phone
text messages
sending postcards whatever you can do to
engage in your democracy
the time is now
to save it from the fear and the profits
that's it
[ __ ] the gqp is your message [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them stick around we'll
be right back right after this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking us through the break
you know we broadcast here every single
week day monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page
uh i see i see a couple things in here
uh
here's the mr canada says tyt is telling
their voters not to vote yeah this is
really [ __ ] dumb this is really
[ __ ] dumb if you're gonna listen to
liberals out there that are telling you
oh it's all the same don't vote don't
donate
you're losing your democracy
you're losing your democracy you
remember in 2016 when when the whole
bernier bust movement was happening you
remember that bernie or bust movement
well here's the bust
here's the bus the bust was not in 2016.
that wasn't the bust
we we are at the brink of the bust now
this is the bust that you were looking
for
so stop listening to [ __ ] out
there telling you both the same you're
not it's not going to help you blah blah
blah but they're [ __ ] they're
gaslighting you they're lying to you
it's all [ __ ]
you just go you just go look at the two
chambers
in our congress the senate and the house
you look at the bills that are sitting
at the feet of the senate and the only
reason they can't move is because you
don't have enough [ __ ] republicans
not democrats you got plenty of
democrats behind those bills you don't
have enough [ __ ] republicans not one
not [ __ ] one
will [ __ ] stand up to codify roe v
wade not a goddamn single one
and it's the democrats fault [ __ ] you
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
goddamn [ __ ]
turn that [ __ ] [ __ ] off if you're
watching something if you're listening
to someone and they're telling you that
stupid [ __ ] turn them the [ __ ] off come
over here i'll give it to you [ __ ]
straight i ain't gonna [ __ ] gaslight
you or [ __ ] you around i'm gonna tell
you exactly how i feel when i feel it
how i feel it just straight to your
[ __ ] from my mouth to your [ __ ]
ear
and i'm not gonna stop i'm not gonna
quit i don't give a [ __ ] every [ __ ]
day two hours a day i'm gonna sit here
and yell and scream into this
[ __ ]
until you turn those other dumb son of a
[ __ ] off turn them off [ __ ] them
if they're saying that [ __ ] enough not
you're done
cast them aside it's enough of that [ __ ]
they don't want anything to do with
saving our democracy
not a goddamn thing they're just trying
to sensationalize whatever the [ __ ]
narrative is
in their little subsect of their
audience
same [ __ ] as fox news newsmax and oan is
doing same [ __ ] [ __ ]
same [ __ ] [ __ ] it's the same
message if you really listen to it same
goddamn [ __ ]
well
tucker carlson well what's the
difference between democrats doing this
and republicans doing this what would be
the difference
what's the difference and listen to some
stupid liberal [ __ ] hack saying that
both sides are the goddamn same
huh
stop
pluck your head out of your ass and
realize that there is something at stake
here and it is called democracy and i
don't give a [ __ ] what your [ __ ]
policy
line by line what you want is it doesn't
matter it doesn't i don't give a [ __ ]
if you want 25
an hour minimum wage instead of 15. i
don't give a [ __ ] if you want all your
student debt paid for as opposed to 10
dollars
i don't care if you want full universal
health care as opposed to some common
sense health care reform that can help
people
i don't give a [ __ ] if you just want
kids to start school at three instead of
five instead of universal pre-k and
college i don't give a [ __ ] you will
have none of that absolutely none of
those line items not a single [ __ ]
one if you let these fascists win not a
goddamn one of them
so politicize the [ __ ] out of
everything [ __ ] everything politicize
the [ __ ] out of it
because there's two things and i'll keep
saying it there's two things at stake
here there's government which is policy
that's what everyone keeps bitching
about
that's what everyone wants to [ __ ]
change
but the only way to govern the only way
to do policy is to [ __ ] win elections
the politics
so yeah it's time to it's time to take
off the gloves
and to play politics that's what we have
to do
to save our democracy
[ __ ] them
that's what we have to do and that's
what i'm gonna do
i'm not gonna do both sides this [ __ ]
[ __ ] ridiculous
i know there's someone else that's
absolutely pissed off about this report
and i'm going to go to the video
my co-host
gabe sanchez an executive producer gabe
i know you've done several videos uh
well what was that on uvault and i know
you have another one coming up today
this report comes out
and it's clear now more than ever
that
we've been lied to from the very
beginning and they're still scapegoating
[ __ ] this one oh yeah he's pretty i mean
you you you have to remember that august
2020
a law enforcement agencies from five
different or law enforcement officer of
officers from five different agencies
were trained inside the hallways of a
school in uvalde texas that was august
2020 then you've got a police chief uh
pete oredondo he had training in
december uh well also in august of 2020.
he had training in uh december of 2021.
you fast forward
to to may
of 2022
and everything that they were trained to
do everything that they were told that
they had to do to prevent
as deterrent as a way to stop them
prevent them from coming into the school
they failed at every single moment that
they had a chance to prevent 21 people
from dying they could have stopped him
outside didn't do it they could have
stopped him inside didn't do it they
blamed it on the door they said we
didn't have a key turns out the door was
able to just open up right like
the shooter came in with intent he knew
where he was going we talked about on
the show and last week or the week prior
or the last week when when the when the
video was released
we talked about how he went in with
intent right he had ven like he went
to go after whether it was his teacher
or someone else from fourth grade but
something was triggering enough that he
had to go back directly to that
classroom
and each point along the way
all of the police saw the law
enforcement officers
they failed they failed at every point
because you know understandably so you
don't want to get [ __ ] shot up by an
ar-15 it's a scary [ __ ] thing
especially for someone who is trained
like even for someone who's trained it's
probably very scary right to to it to in
that moment say well this could be the
end of me because it this gun [ __ ]
i'm not i it is is a way to slaughter
people and that's what happened in
uvalde but these officers detained
people outside who were parents who were
willing to go in unprotected to get
their own kids and mind you that the
police that were outside holding these
these people back
there were other officers that went in
to save their own children they took
priority of their own children before
others
which i get if you're a parent you want
to protect you want to serve that kid
but you also made an oath to protect and
serve that community of yuvaldi and
again at each point they failed they
failed to act that inaction cost the
lives of 21 people
and now they're going to blame it on
doors now they're going to blame it on
defenses yeah well i mean i mean this is
you know and they aren't they that the
report did it is a
a very uh
really stark indictment of the police
department and their systematic failure
uh apparently they didn't even have a
command post uh and to know who is even
in command and no wonder no wonder those
officers were standing around in the
hallway trying to figure out what the
hell was happening and i guess there was
confusion whether it was an active
shooter or if it was a barricaded person
they couldn't figure that the [ __ ] out
because they didn't have proper command
there were so many things that they
failed to do even though they were
trained to do it and that is the thing
folks that is the thing that yes
absolutely in a situation like this
local law enforcement state law
enforcement and these agencies are going
to fail in some instances because they
have a gun in the situation
they're this is the first time and i and
i learned this this morning too which is
absolutely devastating to these [ __ ]
boneheads who talk about law abiding gun
owners and all this [ __ ] this is the
first time this [ __ ] ever
[ __ ] fired a weapon the first time
and he fired a hundred rounds in two and
a half minutes before those police could
even enter the building it's absolutely
absolute insanity to me that they
[ __ ] yammer on and on and on about
law-abiding citizens and gun training
and oh it's it's all about your [ __ ]
to protect yourself and
blah blah blah all [ __ ] every
[ __ ] last bit of it is [ __ ]
because there is no [ __ ] cause for
anyone any i don't care who the [ __ ] you
are to go down to a store
get a [ __ ] piece of of hardware
that's a weapon of war with 1700 [ __ ]
rounds without paying a goddamn dime all
on credit without ever happening to
[ __ ] fire a weapon ever before in
your life just pick the son of a [ __ ]
up load it run to the school because we
also find out the piece of information
in this report
that apparently this kid had some
revenge for that classroom we talked
about it when we broke down the tape
last week i said it he skipped those
classrooms it's almost like he knew
where he was going right and you said it
long before i even brought it up with
the tape that he was from that school
i think you even said i don't know if it
was privately or in one of your videos
that that classroom had something to do
with his mindset right and and obviously
he had a rare a very very very toxic
mindset and greg abbott and the
republicans and the nra in that state of
texas and frankly all around the country
allowed that that
person to act on that toxic mindset and
murder 19 children and two teachers
they let that happen the blood is on
their hands
and if you don't see it that way you
need to pluck your head
out of your [ __ ]
because that is what is happening all
around the country this good samaritan
[ __ ] in indiana oh my god now it's no
longer a good guy with the gun gabe it's
good samaritan right they're going to
redefine it read label they're going to
it's it's the complete you know it is
the number one play out of the
republican playbook let's talk about
revising the story right he's not a good
guy he's a good samaritan hey guys it's
gender neutral he's a samaritan like
[ __ ] these republicans right i'm sure
someone's going to make that argument
like guys guys we're not going to guys
we're not going to women ladies boys
we're calling the samaritans they're
gender neutral see you like pronouns you
know it's like
the the republicans that that come into
the argument and try to say this one
example
where a good samaritan or a good guy
with the gun
did this well let's look at back how the
laws change for open carry and not
having to actually reveal you carry a
gun which was what july first so we're
talking seven 16 15 16 days prior
this loss passed allows anyone to carry
without any sort of and he was bragging
about it right greg abbott was like yay
now anyone can get a gun who has a toxic
mindset and wants revenge for a
classroom that he hasn't been in in
years right
and and
and god god forbid we stop him from
obtaining a weapon of war in 17 rounds
to go take revenge on a classroom
that doesn't even have the teacher or
the students in it but that's not what
matters here and they'll blame it on
that they're going to say oh this guy
was deranged he had he had revenge
so why are you letting him have a gun
then you dummies right like
you know
again it comes back
the perfect example that everyone will
use and everyone should use
is how much training it requires you to
get a license you are driving a weapon
that thing will [ __ ] things up okay even
the smallest thing you're [ __ ]
driving a beetle that thing will still
[ __ ] you up
you are driving a piece of machinery
that has
oil gas
uh a high-powered engine
uh there's ignition there's fire there's
all of these things that you know upon
impact or other things can cause a great
amount of damage to one person or one
thing or an area right
to get a license you have to get hours
of training
hours of training
behind the wheel you have to get
training
in a classroom you have to get training
to get your permit you have to get
training
to take the test to get your license
which includes a written portion you
have to prove that you have the hours of
training you have to prove that you can
actually pass the exam in person hands
behind the wheel 10-2 or 9-3
you have to prove that you are
adequately and sufficiently trained
to operate this vehicle we have
different classes there's a commercial
license that you can get uh there's
there's a you know if you want to get
the the trucker you know like even if
you've wanted to uh power a motorcycle
you have to get a specific if the class
for that well you mean you have to be
trained to drive a motorcycle this is
crazy this is crazy that you have to be
trained to operate what what kind of
liberty do we live under when you can't
protect yourself with a motorcycle and
have to be regulated by the government
and you get regulated somebody brought a
thing in here to sell taxes on the
street is a higher bar than being a cop
like you again you have to get a permit
and a license and apply and go through
the all the red tape that you have to do
to get
your own
street card like even if you're on the
street and you're like i'm sorry well
gabe but gabe but gabe you could make
people sick with with with food right
people sick somebody gets sick right
right i mean i mean they really could
even die you could kill a person
with a taco if you make them sick enough
i mean it is possible why would we want
to make sure that you don't get a person
sick
are people sick i mean you regulate the
sale of
cigarettes we regulate the sale of food
we well we
regulate the [ __ ] we regulate the [ __ ]
out of who you can have sex with
apparently who you can't have sex with
regulating [ __ ] out of medical
procedures that women can have they want
to regulate the [ __ ] out of travel for
women even they want to regulate the
[ __ ] out of that this is not this is not
big government small government type
[ __ ]
listen this is about fascism and fear
and profit that is what it's about
it is about profit and fear to strike
fear in your heart
and for you to do nothing about it
besides go buy another [ __ ] gun
which is again the exact problem that we
have
this idea that a a person went inside
the indiana mall and took out this
person who had a a high-powered rifle
who killed three and injured two like
it's not the per the answer isn't
another person with a
gun like oh oh okay one time one time a
good samaritan
that's not the answer the answer is not
another gun the answer
lies in the first gun the very first one
it's the [ __ ]
gun yep
it's always been the [ __ ] gun it will
continue to be the gun
but for republicans they look at
everything you could literally show them
all of this proof right they know that
they're wrong they know 100
that what happened was the fault of the
gun and the laws they put in place to
make it easy to access and get that gun
to bring it to a school or bring it to a
mall or bring it to a theater or bring
it to a church or bring it to a grocery
store
or bring it to a you know a a a
preschool or a kindergarten like all of
these places again that we
were
told would be safe
right these places we could go to be
with our friends and our family and not
have to worry about the dangers of the
street coming into the the the safety of
our own home or a school or a church or
whatever it was
but now
everyone has to be on [ __ ] alert now
i i want to bring up one kind of like
example here let's say everyone can have
their own gun okay let's just go through
that scenario because that's what
republicans want
let's say that that would be good for
profits right no totally yeah so let's
say you're at the mall right or you're
at the movie theater or whatever it
might be or your grocery store
somebody comes in with the gun they
start shooting another person says oh
[ __ ] pew pew time to go let's pull
out the gun they've got their own gun
they start shooting at the person with
the original gun somebody else comes out
and doesn't know the context here's the
gun shooting and goes oh [ __ ] pew pew i
gotta shoot this guy with a gun but what
they do is they shoot the second guy
with the gun not the original gunman who
is the actual threat so now you get a
fourth person that comes out and goes oh
[ __ ] pew pew
and he wants to shoot one of these other
guys maybe he shoots the third guy maybe
he shoots the first guy but what you're
now seeing is that
all of these people that thought they
were the good guy
are killing other people
who are actually the bad guy right these
good samaritans are killing good
samaritans now like that's the reality
that they would live in is they say well
if a good guy with a bad guy with a gun
comes in then the only people i can stop
is a good guy but what happens if other
good guys
kill the other good guys in the scenario
then you're back to [ __ ] square one
and then when the police finally show up
it looks like a goddamn movie scene
where people have been slaughtered in a
mall
why are logic
no it doesn't make any sense well i
think we know that the answer is not
more guns i mean
obviously obviously 400
trained officers with [ __ ] firearms
in uvalde 400 more [ __ ] weapons which
actually it's probably more i don't know
how many sidearms those cops had on them
with their long guns and everything else
right so i mean you you could make the
case that it's 400 officers but it's
possible that you could have 450 500
guns was not the answer it didn't help
it didn't do anything
nothing
yeah because they didn't act
and the reason why they didn't act is
because of the gun that was in the room
they were terrified of it and like you
said being ripped apart by an ar-15
these cops want to go home to their
families which is uh
another absurdity that we have in our
country that these cops somehow are
tough guys but but they they're so
terrified of their job it really this
and i said this in the beginning this
fascist [ __ ] is the weakness that our
country has that's a weakness liberalism
is actual strength liberalism is [ __ ]
hard it's [ __ ] difficult
in a liberal democracy
to come to cons to some consensus
and let me tell you the fact of the
matter is on the ground there in uvalde
they had no consensus they had no
command they had no leadership because
they're weak they're weak they're
[ __ ] weak because we have put
ourselves in this culture of [ __ ]
fascism especially in our law
enforcement agencies especially when
they're when they're thinking about
[ __ ] active shooters
sir sir sir calling him sir
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
do something save those children right
that's your job and they did nothing i
want to go to the tweety tweets and the
training drinks yes gabe i got a lot of
stuff to round up today yeah i want to
watch this video of this state rep uh
real quick uh talking about fences and
doors no but i also there's some other
video that i want to get to
and there's some other issues out there
as well not just the shivaldi and the
indiana shooting of course guns is the
issue every single day in our country
because we have to deal with it every
single moment no matter where we go so
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast we have reached the
part where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends and there's
a ton of stuff from the weekend uh
there's just speaking of speaking of dip
shits with guns and dangerous people
with guns you've seen the video the
short little clip that ronnie jackson
put out on twitter oh my god this
[ __ ] guy
to me and we're gonna show the video but
to me gabe it felt like he was so in a
hurry to get this video done so he could
put down the guns and pick up the bottle
like he was like look can we just get
this over with real quick yeah he's like
dr ronnie jackson here uh
self-medicating
i might add you know like he's like
straight to the whiskey or whatever his
choice of alcohol is this guy puts down
the guy i bet he drinks he shoots
himself on the foot you know
i bet he drinks vodka oh i think he
drinks vodka i don't know i think ronnie
drinks everclear
i think at this point like he's got a
drink
he's like i don't need to keep drinking
more of this thing i need to figure out
what is more potent so i can drink less
of it so it's less apparent that there's
a glass on my hand everywhere i go
so i think he's drinking he's probably
[ __ ] just
you know do you think that's what trump
has on ronnie somehow like some
something that he's done when he was
drunk
because because i i posed the question
this morning that what does trump have
and elise stefanik because you watch
this [ __ ] interview with mark levin
jesus christ this [ __ ] gaslighting
[ __ ] you talk about a lion piece
of [ __ ] elise stefanik well it's the
same it's the same that tom cotton
brought last week which was oh man
100 made so much money under uh joe
biden and it's like dude one he doesn't
work
under joe biden he doesn't work for the
administration isn't using nepotism to
get new deals right now or anything like
that
ivanka and jared made 640 million during
the presidency and then
jared made an additional 2 billion
for his
investment firm
so these two
are making almost three billion dollars
through their association or connection
to trump and his time as president
and then at least stephanik's like whoa
what about hunter boyden
it's absolutely insane
it's insanity it's insanity that we have
to deal with these [ __ ] lying pieces
of [ __ ]
you remember elise stefanik was she ran
as a non-trump republican do you think
it's the cocaine sex orgies that she
he's gotta know man i don't know we're
gonna watch some of this video this
piece of [ __ ] you know
because she she totally she totally is
um
i mean straight sick a fan it's gross
yeah and i mean she even she even looks
like she has a little bit of throw up in
her mouth when she comes up with some of
these answers i don't know i mean all
these people all these republicans who
come back have been rolling around like
they've made their bed and they're now
rolling around in the [ __ ] that is the
bed that they made and then they get up
and they're like oh god got a little
[ __ ] here on the shoulders that's gross
well let's go to this get off the nose
you know right well that might be
another thing maybe she's maybe she's
into the booger sugar i don't know
and he's got the goods on her he's got
something on her though i know he does
here is the
now this is a state representative and i
i don't have his name offhand it might
say it here on the video i i forget but
he's a republican of course in texas and
that's why he's [ __ ] gaslighting
people about these the fences and the
doors let's listen to this piece of [ __ ]
let me say this
with hindsight we can say the rob
elementary was not adequately prepared
for the risk of a school shooter
the school's five foot fence was
inadequate despite a policy of locked
doors there was a regrettable culture of
non-compliance what in the [ __ ] does a
foot fans have to do with a gun what in
the [ __ ] does it have to do also this is
a this is joe moody by the way oh joe
moody yeah [ __ ]
texas state rep joe moody and yo yo if
you can hear my voice [ __ ] you you piece
of [ __ ] here's what i'll tell you why in
the [ __ ] why in the [ __ ] would a chain
link fence stop anyone what the [ __ ] are
you talking about if he really wanted to
go in and kill people he can get a
[ __ ] pair of [ __ ] wire cutters and
a pair of bolt cutters just as easily as
he can get a gun right and if you're not
[ __ ] listening to me out there
literally this kid got a gun just as
easy as he could walk in to a [ __ ]
hardware store
on credit and buy a set of [ __ ]
bolt cutters to nip a fence right to nip
a hole in a goddamn 12-foot i mean
you're looking for [ __ ] dumb and the
other thing too is to think that this
kid couldn't obtain another something
else to [ __ ] break a door lock you
people are dumb he he could he obtained
the gun easier than he got those [ __ ]
tools to get to the fence and get to the
door moody you can sit down and shut the
[ __ ] up it is enough of this nonsense
that we have to turn [ __ ] into prisons
to make them safe from a gun [ __ ] he
could fire through the fence at people
for crying out loud get the [ __ ] out of
here with that nonsense the fence
they spent more time measuring the
[ __ ] fence than trying to figure out
how the [ __ ] that this kid got a [ __ ]
gun
in fact all three exterior doors to the
building were unlocked that day can you
imagine can you imagine doors
doors being unlocked what the [ __ ] is
this nonsense 30 40 years ago there
weren't they weren't locking school
doors do you know why they weren't
locking school doors gabe do you know
why they weren't [ __ ] locking school
doors because people weren't running
around with weapons of war all over the
place
this is really [ __ ] bone-headed i
mean the other the other thing too is
you know he talks about the fence he
talks about the doors it's like okay
remember
he just drove his car
into the ditch right whether he crashed
it swerved it
whatever right i i actually i actually
think he was he i mean this this he was
not in his in a very toxic set of mind
yeah and he was gonna try to drive in
that ditch to hide that to hide that but
he's got he's got an ar-15 with a ton of
rounds to go slaughter whoever's in that
school in that classroom right
he has a car he has a truck he's a car
whatever
are you going to tell me that that car
again which is considered a a weapon
right that's why people get vehicular
manslaughter used it that way
you have to get training to drive the
car he could use that car to drive
through a fence to drive through a door
any one of those three unlocked doors if
it really was a problem he [ __ ] ram
right through get out of the car go
through into the school and do what he
wanted to do he could have shot the
locks he could have shot the windows
he'd get it what if he didn't have a gun
but what if he didn't have a gun
he would have to punch his way through
what if he didn't have what if he what
if he didn't have a gun gabe what if he
didn't have a gun that could fire a
hundred rounds in two and a half minutes
then what then what
what what what would we do what would we
do
if if if a mass shooter wouldn't
couldn't obtain a weapon of war what
would we do gabe what what kind of
liberty is that i know for crying out
loud what kind of liberty is that that a
mass shooter a murderer can't access a
weapon of war how [ __ ] ridiculous
does that sound get them it it air the
fact the fact that the second amendment
is more important than the lives
of innocent americans
is [ __ ] messed up
i mean that's just the that's just as
simple as i can say it the fact that the
second amendment
is jamie jamie's saying that that's not
joe moody i thought that was joe moody i
don't i don't know who this guy is but
he's a state rep i know he's a
republican i want i see i've seen his
name earlier but i'm not i don't recall
and and really honestly doesn't matter
at this point they all look so [ __ ]
generic i mean look at this [ __ ]
he looks like he walked out of a young
republicans club
and and you know and talks about how he
hates gay marriage he doesn't like he
doesn't like math he hates crt
i mean look at him look at this
[ __ ] sorry joe moody sorry they
are right joe moody is is sitting to i
believe to the right of this oh okay so
joe needs the other [ __ ] yeah yeah
but not the [ __ ] speaking here no no
i'll find that name in this okay
and multiple interior doors were not
secured the day of the shooting
when i talked about the false sense of
security i do not believe
uvalde consolidated or rob elementary is
the only school with these issues in it
yeah it's not it's not the only because
that that school was not built
in in the mindset of oh you know what
what if someone comes in and tries to
mass murder these children who we
literally in this country right now
there are people designing schools
elementary schools they're sitting down
designing elementary schools with the
forefront thought of what if someone
comes in here and tries to mass
slaughter these children and what is
supposed to be the safest place on earth
you [ __ ] sick sons of [ __ ] and
this [ __ ] to sit here and
gaslight not only texas but the parents
of the 19 slaughtered children to act
like a locked door
is the thing that murdered and
and tore apart their children is [ __ ]
disgusting vile and [ __ ] this guy this
guy shouldn't be running his dog catcher
as far as i'm concerned just because he
has republican after his [ __ ] name
and this is what you get this is what
you get folks when you vote these
[ __ ] generic [ __ ] vile fascist
racist pieces of [ __ ] in office just
like this [ __ ] cookie cutter white
guy this is what you get representative
dustin burrows yeah dustin
the other the other there is still is
there still is a very well intentioned
[ __ ] you to joe moody that's next to him
because joe moody went on uh social
media last week after the video was
released and tried to justify the
actions of the gentleman that was
looking through the phone that had the
punisher
uh background on his screen and then try
to say that gentleman was the the
husband of the teacher who was killed
right which makes it even worse right
like
the fact that you're waiting there not
doing anything you find out this is your
wife's school i don't know it doesn't
really make it sound that better of a
situation
to justify that person's actions just
standing around right so that was moody
that sent that out on social media moody
said that on social media last week
anything but the gun right anything but
exactly
blame anything but the gun he's like
let's take it easy on the officer what's
what's this guy's name speaking again
what's his name is dustin burrows dustin
yeah of course his [ __ ] name is
dustin hey dustin if you can hear me i
will welcome you to come on this show i
will [ __ ] open you up to a whole
goddamn hour to let you [ __ ]
try to tell me how it's [ __ ] fences
and doors use piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] come
on the show come on the show and tell me
you fun explain to me
to my [ __ ] face how those parents
lost their children
got them ripped apart had to identify
them by their [ __ ] shoes because of a
locked door come on this show i
challenge you to come on this show and
explain it to me to my [ __ ] face i
dare you i think it would be a great
piece of content to watch this
[ __ ] explain to me why it's the
doors let's do that dustin you piece of
[ __ ] i've talked to enough other
educators around the state to believe
this is a wider problem that we need to
continue to look at
yeah he's real [ __ ] oh a wider
problem that the doors the doors and the
size of the fences is a wider problem
that the state legislator needs to focus
on we need to run around the state
measuring measuring the height of the
fences what a dumb [ __ ] what a
dumb [ __ ] hey dustin hey dustin
spend two [ __ ] seconds two [ __ ]
seconds looking at the facts and
understanding you need to concentrate
more on why the [ __ ] he got that gun why
he got 1700 rounds and why that gun is
on the streets of your state you piece
of [ __ ]
it shouldn't be any it should not be
surprising either you look at the things
that they say which is like oh well guys
guys guys
let's look at all of the schools in the
area let's look at the whole state of
texas
there are uh squeaky doors that need
wd-40 and that would allow someone to
come in there are chain-link fences that
aren't triple bolted they're like they
will come up with anything that is not
the gun remember they will they will
point and they will look and say well
it's not just it's not just here it's
not just here guys it wasn't it's not
just an isolated incident
it is though
but a larger problem and that problem
isn't doors as in fences it is the guns
it is the the well-regulated militia
that is the police force
if if police were fined with guns in
certain areas why can't you bring a gun
into a police station
if you're not a police officer right why
can't you blink guns into a courtroom
right that would make it really unsafe
to have guns in the courtroom that would
make it really why are all of these
places banned that are of official state
municipal or government level that you
can't bring a gun into you can't bring a
gun into the nra but they don't they
don't want guns to threaten them gabe
they would much rather have them
threaten people at a mall or people out
of elementary school look you know the
problem in indiana and you know maybe
dustin is [ __ ] right the problem in
indiana at that mall that this just
defense was not high enough outside that
mall right and the doors weren't locked
the fence should have been higher right
should have had spawn
it should have been one of those great
beautiful fences that they should have a
[ __ ] moat a gun moat yeah a gun mode
right right you know
and maybe like watch towers you know and
barbed wire and again we're coming back
to it sounds like you're building a
prison right well i mean that's the
thing is in indiana that mall that that
that's the real issue the reason why the
good samaritan with a gun had to go in
and shoot the shooter is because there
just wasn't high enough fences and there
wasn't enough locked doors on that mall
good god what is wrong with us this is
just [ __ ] ridiculous shannon watts
points this out and it's really easy
it's the guns it's the guns and of
course she gives statistics here but
it's not hard to see of why the united
states has more
deaths per hundred thousand people it's
because we got more guns that's the only
reason more guns means more gun deaths
means more gun violence that's just how
it works it's not [ __ ] complicated it
really isn't and this is this exact
point is something i cover in the first
video i did which was on uvalde for the
what was that series and it talks about
how
there are more gun deaths
because of
the gun violence the access to guns we
have more gun related debts in america
than we do
others right these are these are things
that can be prevented right if we had a
proper regulation training assessment
licensing uh retraining i mean you have
to go in and get a [ __ ] test and you
know and and make sure that you are
still able to drive that car right
like if your license expires you have to
go and have to go through certain
hurdles to make sure that you are
properly trained and that you should
still have that car and that license
it should be no different with the gun
all we're asking we're not going to take
away your [ __ ] guns okay we're not
coming into your home and stealing your
guns out of your safe if you even have
them in your safe but we're not doing
that what we're asking is a simple
request
just be trained
make sure that when you buy the gun
you are actually trained to operate that
gun
well you know the proper
yeah well i think you're making good
points here but here's the thing is here
is a person who is supposed to be
trained with a weapon this person is a
former military he was a doctor and it
floors me that this [ __ ] here
this crazy
loon
was actually inside the white house in
several administrations right next to
the president of the united states it is
absolutely batshit crazy
that that is a [ __ ] thing that
happened
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with us like
jesus christ you know we're we're
raising a lot of questions about the
secret service over the last few weeks
and the coming months i'm sure once we
find out what happened with some of
these secret service agents
but but this guy right here was he was
responsible
for several administrations to make sure
that that the president had proper
medical care and this guy's this is also
the same guy who said the president was
the healthiest president that we've had
right sir okay and
robbie points out a great point here
because he's supposed to be well trained
and this goes to your point is even
well-trained people are [ __ ] dumb
right especially after they had some
drinks right well i again i think that's
what the video shows why is he aiming it
at his foot that's a good question why
does he have two of these guns i have no
money is he going out like [ __ ] rambo
to go shoot deer or as they said oh yeah
we use ar-15s to shoot [ __ ] prairie
dogs and possums why are you using a
high-powered rifle to kill something
that is no bigger than this the other
thing that i want to know is where is he
at this fence is obviously not high
enough to keep to keep this this bad guy
i don't know he's in a cemetery just
preparing
but the [ __ ] defense is not high
enough here gabe no yeah i mean that
fence clearly clearly dustin needs to
needs to get on this and legislate
because that's where ronnie jackson is
from so that's where i can only assume
in these ad is maybe he's in texas here
i mean he could be in washington he is a
representative but but he's got his
texas shirt on there he's got his red
texas shirt on there he he forgot his
three percenter his domestic terrorism
shirt that he that he wears around but
that fence is clearly not high enough to
protect anyone from this psycho with a
gun that fence is just not adequate
enough yeah he could hop over that fence
maybe or maybe
like it looks like it's like the fence
and that doesn't look like it looks like
a cemetery that i can't be the only one
here but like i said it looks like he's
in a cemetery it could be yeah or he's
outside of the cemetery i don't know he
looks like he's near a cemetery here's
the thing though is in this in this in
this clip he's trying to go very fast
like he's so [ __ ] in a hurry to put
these guns down so he can pick up the
bottle again watch
hey everybody this is congressman ronnie
jackson from the great state of texas i
have a message for the biden
administration if you're thinking about
taking our ars you can start here in
texas on behalf of all the law-abiding
gun owners in the state of texas i just
want to say come and get it come and get
it it's it's actually come and take them
yeah yeah
they love that
if you want something
come and take it
so i can
then use self-defense right right and
use my gun
after i shoot my foot i will shoot you
that's that's the thing they're trying
to you they're they're trying to
instantly it is very threatening for
them to say
if you want the [ __ ] guns you got to
come and take them come and get them i
swear you know it's like it's like no
one again we don't want to take your
guns i mean obviously if you're not well
equipped you're under the influence and
you're not someone maybe mentally that
should have a gun yeah you shouldn't
have a gun so we should probably remove
that from the area so that you don't
harm others in your community or in your
home or in your school or your church or
whatever it might be
well i mean that's all that's all good
points and malcolm nance makes a good
point here he says
that's why i retweeted it dickwad that's
a great i mean there is no
better description of ronnie jackson
than dickwad right like that that's me
is malcolm nance still in ukraine i i'm
not really sure where what his status is
and where malcolm's at but he he makes
and really he could have just stopped at
dickwad at dickwad and that could have
been the tweet shut up dig what right
just hear it yeah dick one yeah anybody
but he continues in in in great fashion
he says they will come and take it
moments after you shoot yourself in the
foot with that negligent careless way
you're handling that firearm hashtag
[ __ ] idiot
and this is supposed to be someone who's
trained with weapons right ronnie j even
though he is a doctor he was in the
military he ended train with weapons
yeah and he still and obviously he
doesn't know how to run a scale because
he thinks donald trump weighs 125 pounds
but he can't handle he can't operate a
[ __ ] weapon either just like he can't
operate escape people people uh people
in the comments have
let me know that malcolm nance is back
because he does have that book tour that
he's doing which oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay okay uh which is back from ukraine
yeah yeah yeah okay good but you would
never find ronnie jackson going
willingly to go serve in hails to the no
he would never do that he'll come and
take my guns but i will never i will
never want to pew pew pew
uh elsewhere right like he's like i was
trained to use his weapon and i own
these weapons because i have a small ass
dick and i've got insecurities and an
ego problem
you know
speaking more of a dum dum [ __ ] with
guns here's a video that patriot takes
put out or
ted nugent this is this is more of this
dumb stupid [ __ ] where they're
appropriating culture and [ __ ] and
they're making it into guns he literally
makes it sound like rosa park had a gun
on a bus and he's rosa parks yeah he's a
blind
quality oh my god if you're ever going
to be getting a comparison to be like
i'm like rosa just stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop right there don't don't
don't don't do it don't don't do it no
matter how much of a hero you are really
yeah even if you truly are a rosa parks
type don't that's not it's not a good
idea you're not no you're not going to
end well you're not in the same
situation you're not fighting for the
same thing and what you are fighting for
is uh not at all equivalent or
incomparable in any way and it's that
uh
delusion
of people on the right where they're
like my rats to not wear a mask or not
get a vaccine and shoot my gun pew pew
pew like all these people it's like no
no no
you're just [ __ ] dumb and you're
complaining you're whining about [ __ ]
right these are the same people that
want to take away um
birth control and plan b right like oh
we need the fda to regulate to take it
out and it's like but we also want the
fda to allow us people to take over mech
and we have covets like you dumb [ __ ]
you can't have it both ways that's this
group they try to they
they either don't pick a lane i think
dakota said it best in an interview he's
like they don't pick a lane
so
they can never be wrong right and what i
said was oh i think they drive between
the lanes so that they can you know they
can say
oh i was swerving here or swerving there
but i think you know either one is right
where it's they will neither pick a lane
or drive in the middle just be like i
was never wrong i was always right
janie from facebook uh puts it correctly
[ __ ] you ted nugent
that's appropriate um you know what i
don't even think i don't think i'm gonna
play this now now that everyone knows
just [ __ ] that nugent because what he
does is he compares himself to rosa park
and it's really gross you can go you can
go watch it i mean anybody also anyone
that you see it happens a lot on the
republican side the right wing people
will quote it will here will misquote
um martin luther king jr
right they will misquote
or co-opt
the narrative
of what he was fighting for and then try
to use it for their own thing whether
it's wrong covet or vaccines or guns or
whatever it might be this is the same
people that take his message
and try to drag it as their own
and disparage him by doing so and then
go i'm not racist
i love malcolm
i like malcolm x i like martin luther
king jr or like rosa parks we're all the
same we're all fighting for the same
things those same rights
again do not try to compare yourself
with these people
because the things that you're fighting
for are not at all same as what they
fought for
and you're also
trying to take those things away
right now
the things that they fought for they're
trying to take away
we'll talk about messaging because i
think i think it's important messaging
um hal points out something because
senator ted cruz not only did he go on
uh squawk box here but he actually
posted this video
he actually posted this video
and and hal says i'm enjoying the split
screen of this [ __ ] sticky hammering
while oil is dropping below a hundred
dollars due to biting strategy now we
know your crude is is bouncing up and
down but it's hovering around 100 a
barrel which is the reason why gasoline
prices are dropping
because the supply chain is being
appropriately mandated by the
administration now it's not going to be
a permanent fix but it's going to get us
through hopefully this situation of the
supply problem uh the uh the you um
the ue actually
did a deal with another country uh this
morning that used to be a soviet country
and they're going to try to fix their
supply problem which will help crude
prices around the world so this this
situation
is is is working but here's here's ted
cruz talking about
gas prices being high as it literally
right on the screen
is dropping watch
well look it it is indicative of the
messed up priorities of this white house
you you look at
uh
out of control gasoline prices you look
at a a war in europe the first major
land war in europe since world war ii
what we ought to be doing is unleashing
u.s production the high point for u.s
production was in 2019 we were produced
he literally did that
i like it that is literally what the guy
who you're claiming is full of [ __ ] and
he's not doing anything he literally did
this thing that you're saying yeah not
only did he do that he went beyond that
and actually went to have other people
around the world release their reserves
to fix the supply problem right he
encounters i mean joe biden you know
does control the global prices and
inflation across the world right
he's able at the switch
here's the thing
joe biden is so powerful and so omni
he's so present
but he's sleepy and he doesn't know
anything and he's just he's so but it's
pretty amazing that joe sleepy joe biden
incompetent sleepy joe biden was able to
win the presidency
thanks to george soros
but only take 50 seats in the [ __ ]
senate right like these are things that
you you you hear these stories of joe
biden he's like oh man this guy's
sleeping in the basement he's hiding in
the basement
he's accomplished a lot from the
basement i guess because
look at what he's doing
he has been able like look at what
happened with mexico he was able to go
to mexico and say hey we should figure
out a deal for
how we should repair the wall right that
we have at the southern border how we
should invest in technology right we're
going to get you to pay 1.5 billion
dollars toward this investment
trump
he was like these rapists and these
criminals and that like fellow mexicans
right my family in mexico he's calling
them rapists and he's calling them drug
dealers and and murderers
and it's like what do you think is going
to happen when you start your your
campaign announcement with that type of
rhetoric and those type of accusations
and then say mexico is gonna pay for the
wall and then mexico was like [ __ ] no
we're not gonna pay for that [ __ ]
wall you [ __ ] idiot you're a bigot
and joe biden comes in he's like hey
maybe
we should work together on something and
mexico was like okay that sounds great
that's good
you're an actual leader you came to us
and had a conversation and willing to
collaborate [ __ ] insane that a world
leader would try to work with other
people but it's no surprising when you
look at trump and all the photos he's
like
i don't want to if i don't get the
credit i'm not going to do it
like i don't need to credit i'm not
going to do it here's another
[ __ ] here's another [ __ ]
trump jr here and i'm not talking about
booger sugar junior i mean well maybe we
should call this death santa's trump 2.0
maybe i don't know yeah yeah i don't
know but look let's listen to this
gaslighting [ __ ] i think that we
have a rule of law in this country and
you don't get to just have a mob descend
on a supreme court justice's house or
try to impede the operations of
government because there may be a
decision you don't like uh that would be
considered an insurrection
what
have you seen this video no i haven't so
this is scary but this was i was like as
soon as he said people descend upon the
government i'm like
are we're just [ __ ] running right
through the point right now oh running
right here burst into it backing up
and running right through again
like the the
oh my god the cognitive dissonance the
the inability
or or ignorance
or naivete whatever you want to call it
the ability for someone like this and
the rest of the republican party to not
look or not you know blind or not not
willing to look just like they're not
willing to look at the guns being the
problem you know they want to place the
blame in antifa blm they want to place
the blame on the left they want to say
that you know all of these people who
broke in smeared [ __ ] on the walls took
took
actual property from
the capital are not insurrectionists the
people that [ __ ] design built broke
down transported rebuilt the gallows and
said they wanted to hang mike pence
they're not insurrectionists they're
just tourists and i think
now that i now i hear myself say it
maybe they mistook the word tourists
right they they in their mind are like
oh terrorists and they're like no that's
what we're ready to do oh it's tourists
right not terry you hear terrorists it
really means tourists
like [ __ ] andrew clyde oh it was just
a normal day just a normal day there's a
normal tour guide going on here yeah you
know that guy you smear [ __ ] and you
throw [ __ ] through the window right
that's what you do on a normal tour
oh [ __ ] that guy and [ __ ] this guy let's
let's this is hilarious this is great
[Music]
so ron desantis i was hoping
my only edit to that would be to have
the video of the guy climbing or the
woman climbing that falls off the wall
yeah that would have been
yeah
maybe even the mario
oh man it happens it happens but that's
a great video uh i think jewish uh
gender resistor put that together
yeah yeah i saw that one logo on the
bottom line go check that one out uh you
know this thursday we have another
hearing speaking of the insurrection
we have another hearing on the in on the
insurrection another chapter in this
verse i guess um
our verse in this chapter what what this
story that we're going to tell adam
kindlinger was on the sunday show uh and
seriously it's season two i'm telling
you i tweeted about it wait wait wait
this is season this is the season one
finale right this is the season one
finale but we're already seen because
okay this is this is what i said online
i said season one is all about world
building okay we're setting up what
happened we have to get context so
you're talking about when they do like a
television series yeah right if i was
writing this
january 6 series right now season one
would be world building you have to
build out the world to establish who the
villain is right who the the antagonist
is right you have to establish who the
protagonists are right you have the
people who are the committee and you
have trump and all the people around him
mainly trump right because he's kind of
like the big evil guy in this situation
and you go through the first season and
you lay out the events you throw in
moments where this person's introduced
and this person comes back you know you
have reoccurring characters cameos right
to help complement whether they're guest
stars or co-stars
now
in august and september as we lead into
the midterms i believe
the second season of the series is to
establish the character arcs or
character development of these other
people
those people being the ones who are
directly involved with the insurrection
who had a part who tried to do something
right you've got
um uh uh heis right from georgia i
believe it is uh who just got subpoenaed
uh you're getting more and more people
right yeah they sent out target letters
here right you guys republicans said hey
we're going to indict you right more
people coming forward
more subpoenas because here's the thing
all the videos we've watched have more
or less been the same like if they're
clipping out stuff from hirschmann or or
bill barr or ivanka it's you know
somewhat similar it's around the same
time of questions that they asked during
the depositions
we're seeing those things kind of come
back through as a as a as a through line
to prove what's going on
but i feel like they've got you know
they've got hours and hours and hours of
depositions right i mean just patsy
bologna has [ __ ] nearly eight hours
of deposition
footage
and they've only shown us so much they
just introduced stephen miller in the
last hearing
so i believe that in the second season
that starts in august or september as we
lead into the midterms they're going to
start identifying the people especially
those who are running for reelection and
i think it's a strong it's a solid and
it's a smart strategy well i i agree
with you because i i think i think this
is going to lead us to more information
that after the august recess they'll
convene and maybe even during the august
recess because that will make it more
significant as well right if if they if
they if they start up season two as you
put it right the character building
really building out each one of these
characters and who they were i mean last
season on this season like they're right
it's that type of recap they do it every
every episode during the hearings
we will show you this next week it's a
preview
last week or yesterday or whenever the
hearing was we showed you this they're
they're recapping you because again
people have been trained
to binge watch or to
you know if they're a week at a time
they go oh wait oh i need i need a quick
recap what the [ __ ] happened because
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] show i've already
covered six of these with what was that
series and i couldn't even get to
everything because i'm trying to cap the
time to be like i know that your time is
valuable and you only have so much so i
can only bring out the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] moments well there was one point
where you were trying to when you were
trying to write one of these and you're
like man it's like nine minutes i'm like
yeah you gotta find something to cut and
like we were we were scouring through
your script to find any little thing
that we could still there's a ton of
jokes that i just so people right
because you're trying to make those
points right exactly uh uh texas paul is
here he's actually uh one of our panel
members one of our panel members thanks
for for coming today he says aim and
gabe um uh so everyone i want to tell
you that the time has been announced on
on this thursday this week and texas
paul will join us
on our panel at least i think he will i
haven't i haven't confirmed it with him
yet i'm i'm kind of putting words in his
mouth i'm assuming i'm assuming texas
has been there he's been through and
through he's been there every single day
every single beginning middle and end
and he gives all of his great comments
he gives us the texas paul oh yeah
commentary that that the mind is
sometimes
we even get some cookies in the
background that's true that's true
jordy's cookies but cookies in the
background but here's the thing here's
the thing is that
everyone needs to remember that thursday
is a prime time hearing right so this is
going to be at a time where it is going
to be most convenient for most people to
watch and i think that's very
significant the other thing that is
going to be super important is they are
going to go through the tick tock of
time of trump right and what he was and
more importantly what he wasn't doing
but let's listen to how adam kensinger
here frames it up 187 minutes
um
you're leading this hearing you you know
what you can present at this point can
you at least tell us if you filled in
the blanks of you know who the president
was actually speaking with
why there weren't phone records for
example of phone calls he may have
placed during that time period we have
filled in the blanks
i can't necessarily say that the motives
behind every piece of information we
know we'll be able to explain but this
is going to open people's eyes in a big
way
the reality is i'll give you this
preview the president didn't do very
much but gleefully watch television
during this time frame
we're going to present a lot more than
that but i could only imagine as i mean
i knew what i felt like as a us
congressman if i was a president sworn
to defend the constitution that includes
the legislative branch watching this on
television i know i would have been
going ballistic to try to save the
capital he did quite the opposite
and that's what you're gonna see on
thursday so everyone join us on thursday
again it's at eight eastern is when the
gavel comes down but we start our
coverage at the midas touch network an
hour before and texas paul will join us
he's in the chat i think texas paul has
become a regular viewer here is that
imagine what they have planned for a
prime time hearing that's right that's
probably true ain't wrong man no this is
not wrong this is going to be the bang
you're revealing this big finale right
whether there's a bit of a cliffhanger
to lead you into the next season or not
but i feel like again everyone wants to
know what happened and we already knew
things too like he was there drinking
his diet coke watching on fox news happy
gleefully like as uh kenzier said he
goes outside makes his announcement
after you know after a while and finally
says
oh i love you go home we care for you
you know all this [ __ ]
and of course it doesn't do anything
right they don't go home they don't they
don't willingly leave the capitol
they had to be forcefully removed
but trump goes out there because it's
feeding his ego and it says these people
will [ __ ] die for me these people
will commit their life
and sedition to make sure that daddy
trump stays in office
and once he saw that once he knew what
they would do
he was like oh no i gotta let it go on
for as long as possible i gotta see how
far they're gonna take this because who
knows maybe they [ __ ] pulled us off
and then he goes that would be [ __ ]
great i would love that
sipping my dr pepper or diet coke
whatever it might be
well i mean sydney powell's the dr
pepper commercial trump's going to be
the dank commercial but i think i think
adam kinzinger get really gets at the
heart of it and he's basically signaling
that yes we are going to find out
america is going to get to know that 187
minutes and really what what what was
going on in real right again more was he
flushing documents was he eating
documents right
i mean to be to be quite honest with you
in the lead up to january 6 in december
he was begging his supporters to come
save him because he knew he'd lost he
knew he'd lost he knew he wasn't going
to be able to use the courts at that
point he he knew that he had exhausted
attorney general barr he exhausted that
measure he exhausted the doj he
exhausted the court systems his only
option at this point was to to pressure
mike pence into making him king and and
then use the violence and have
his [ __ ] you know his
[ __ ] toothless followers to come
[ __ ] intimidate mike pence into doing
what he wanted to do that was it that
was the only that was the only last
measure for that um but here's what i
want to show
is that
because of all this because of
the hearings and because of the truth
coming to power here
you're starting to see the cracks
inside trumpism and i think really a lot
of his supporters who love trump and
love trumpism
they realize that
he really is a toxic
um
a loser a toxic loser and they're
looking for their new fear her um but
this is incredible that they aired this
on fox news now it's fox news digital
right but it is fox news watch
watch how they're trying to shop for a
new furor here i don't want him to i
like uh like what he stands for i like
what he does but uh
he upset too many people and he upset
him really bad so i don't think he's
good for the party he needs to get back
in that he already had gained that
respect from all the world leaders and
finish what he
you know started it's too bad that he
did what he
did do and was fought the whole way
along
on
starting everything that he did but
that's what happened so i like to see
him not run keep in mind he won't say
what he did right well i mean he's like
what he did
what he did
but he's got to reel it in well let me
tell you let me tell you the one thing
that that these trump supporters love
that trump did there is one thing that
he did that they love the [ __ ] out of it
ain't got nothing to do with making sure
rich people don't pay taxes and they got
nothing to do with making sure that
americans pay more for goods by by
putting tariffs on [ __ ] from china and
it got nothing to do with pipelines or
[ __ ] or any of this stuff let's do
it one thing one thing only it gave them
the ability to go out and be brave
enough to voice their white grievance
that is what they [ __ ] loved about
him is that they didn't have to hide
their white grievance anymore they could
just say it right out in the open they
could really they could really get it
out off their chest that they think
they're being oppressed because they're
white that's what they love about him
that's the one thing they love about him
the most and that's why r that's why
they're shopping a new fuhrer here is
because ron desantis allows them to do
that same thing right it just
ron desantis has a better style of
fascism right it's not like buffoonery
it's not like min capoop nazis he's
really trying to be
the actual the actual nazis the actual
hitler here is what he's trying to do
you know trying to be a competent leader
uh and actually commit to a fascist
state not just bumbling and stumbling
around like trump right let's listen
what appears to be a green haired person
but he's just standing underneath the
light this isn't this isn't some kind of
crazy thing where this guy is a libtard
because he has green hair have you seen
this [ __ ] where they think people would
color in here or somehow have a yeah
i mean i know christian walker my uh
online roommate
always complains about blue-haired
liberals blue not green hair blue it's
not green
i mean green hair orange body that's an
oompa loomba right but if you have blue
hair right that is a liptart it's uh
you know it's a blue hair liberal
they're the antifa like that's what
people believe like oh god forbid that i
dyed my hair doesn't what color would
you dye your hair if you had the
opportunity to dye it any color you
could what color would you choose i've
always kind of wanted to bleach my hair
oh she wanted like white
yeah like a like a platinum bleach or
something like that oh so like that
could be cool i don't know like
like like a golden bleach kind of thing
no not like a golden bleach but like a
like a platinum like a silver almost
kind of oh okay you know you see you
want to look old is that what you're
saying no no no because i would still
see my dark hair underneath so it's just
kind of like okay you know i i see
frosted titties i don't i don't know i
don't know just some places i don't have
any style obviously but but the point
you know who else you know who else had
uh dyed hair right yeah no he wasn't
quite blue-haired but the republicans
love to attack us and say that this guy
was antifa is the shooter from highland
park oh yeah in chicago okay yeah he was
attracted they immediately went to this
guy is antifa this guy's hair he's a
liberal
but i want to be clear here this guy
here on the screen does not have colored
areas
it appears to be that he's standing
underneath the green line yeah which was
great positioning by the way emerald
right well whoever was the cameraman
here everyone in the comments are saying
no don't bleach my hair
i'm not gonna do it okay we should do it
now we should do it
you know well gabe doesn't really have
to do anything in his hair he's got a
whole closet full of wigs
gabe rents a whole storage unit just to
keep his wigs in that's how many he has
let's let's listen to this [ __ ] here
for him but i would not recommend he
runs i i voted for trump both times
and i i love him i think he was a good
candidate but i think his time has
passed i couldn't care less about uh
president trump uh personally um
i i'd prefer somebody different but if
he is the nominee i'll probably vote for
him
what what
what in the [ __ ] is it
like they're just like they're walking
around the sidewalk like do you know
anything about politics like nope like
are you a trump supporter yep so you
know nothing about politics you're not
how the government works you don't care
about anything or anyone but you would
vote for him
yeah okay let's get this guy on camera
yeah what in the [ __ ]
i mean i wonder i hear saying i well
i'll let you finish the video and i'll
give context to where these people are
okay okay you know what i voted for him
for my my very first time i voted for
him i don't think it'll be best for our
country for him to
run for re-election you know i'm
thankful for everything that he's done
but i think that our republican party
needs to be united at this point he's a
little too polarizing and i think that
there are candidates out there at this
point
only at this point this lady thinks he's
a little too polarizing i mean you know
they're like now
that the committee has shown what
everyone else was [ __ ] saying was
true right
now that we've seen it in the receipts
are live on tv right now it's a little
bit polarizing right but if it was a
week before the committee hearing
started they were like oh yeah [ __ ]
trump yeah i [ __ ] love that guy oh
yeah yeah yeah he's the kind of fascist
we want right let's listen to this
bonehead listen to who she says would be
the nice replacement for the fear her
republican candidates obviously
that
maybe be able to pull in people that he
would lose to be able to change this i
would like to see you know governor
desantis or someone like that some some
new blood in in the race desantis
if he wants to then he can pick up
donald as the vice president we're from
florida
oh these people obviously have no
[ __ ] idea they have no clue about
anything they're talking about that
they're like oh yeah let's just pick up
yeah donald trump donald trump would nev
he's already had a [ __ ] taste
you think that that [ __ ] is
going to want to say yeah i'll go for vp
no offense you know you know what might
be relatively like
is what that makes sense though gabe it
might make sense though the thing think
about this in the q anon perspective
right put your put your put your tin
foil head on let's say let's say ron
desantis wins okay and trump is his vice
president trump can lay and wait for
four years until then he goes to certify
the vote and he could just declare
himself the winner i mean
he would stand back and stand by right
exactly take over right as president
exactly all right maybe there's
something i'm just saying i'm just
saying
just saying that maybe that's this guy's
theory these people are boneheads i mean
these are the same people like rusty
bowers who said publicly look if trump
what like i don't like trump i think
he's [ __ ] crazy and i think he's a
threat to democracy however with that
being said
if he were the nominee
then yeah i'd vote for him what the [ __ ]
you literally experienced this first
hand rudy giuliani jenna ellis trump and
the rest of those [ __ ] seditionist
[ __ ]
tried to overthrow the the government
and overturn the election they came to
you said they had proof that they had
evidence
that they didn't have that they
eventually admitted that it was all just
theories well you've seen the rusty
bowers story you've seen the update
though haven't you he changed his mind
he has now
he's now changed his mind he he he did
an interview where he said that he would
not support donald trump what he was
trying to say is if the republican party
would nominate him he would consider it
but he believes there's no way that they
will nominate at least even but even the
language of
he would consider it is dangerous right
because that implies that there was even
a remote possibility that he would
actually vote for trump right that he
even took the time to say the guy that
[ __ ] dragged me through the ringer
and made people come to my house
threatening me and my family and my
gravely ill daughter
right you know what he's not well i mean
i mean
again rusty bowers feared prison he
didn't he he would have done it if he
didn't fear prison right yeah i'm sure
and i'm sure that's that you know they
were trying to tell him hey we were
pardoning wink you know i mean i'm sure
that's what was happening let's let's
listen to the
the
the absolute dumb [ __ ] here just a few
seconds left we're big fans of desantis
on this one he seems to be much more
common sense
and able to communicate better to both
sides
to get those people back then
the switch okay i like i'm gonna tell
you what i love i love how this lady
thinks that that ron desantis is
attractive to both sides what is she
talking about yeah both sides he would
be able to talk to both sides nobody on
the left wants to [ __ ] talk to
desantis for all the things he's banning
books don't say gay he wants to take
rights away like who on the left would
ever even even in the middle would ever
consider being like ah he's okay he's
not so bad guys he wants to take a few
rights away but he doesn't want to take
all the rights away well here's one
reason why all
all year long remind us touch writes
this on twitter ron desantis has been
traveling around florida handing out
oversized checks which they paid for as
he takes credit for president biden's
infrastructure bill which desantis
vehemently opposed went around the state
campaigning against biden's
infrastructure policy and both florida
republican senators voted against both
of them both of them voted against and
here here and this is not like um
someone taking pictures this is ron
desantis on his official government
account
actually posting pictures of himself
canning out infrastructure checks that
democrats got and then
earlier i don't know if you heard
but in the first hour someone was
talking about how you know tyt tells
their viewers not to vote or something
like that i'm sure some shows over there
are not saying that but i've watched
over there a lot of those shows are
saying that type of [ __ ] that both sides
are the same and it's blah blah blah
blah blah blah yeah it's how is that
even a comparison well also if you were
to tell people not to vote that's the
dumbest [ __ ] thing i've ever heard
exactly but here here is more proof if
you're wanting it uh over at tyt if if
you're a tyt viewer or you're working
over there
if you need more proof of why they're
not the same here here is exactly the
proof that you need democrats pass this
bill democrats worked their asses off to
[ __ ] compromise with people in their
party just to deliver this to america
[ __ ] scrape right because republicans
did nothing right they didn't none of
them wanted to do anything
and they barely got this through and
only democrats working hard on this even
against themselves in some instances
and in the interest of their party and
their constituents and here ron desantis
is who worked hard not to get it who
used the republican apparatus not to get
it is running around seeing
paying money paying the state's money so
that he can appear in these pictures
with big huge chicks
you know you know who ron desantis
reminds me of
he's the kind of guy when you do a group
project in school right you've got like
a couple people who are like okay guys
we really need to do the job right and
they're like working together they're
putting the slide deck together they're
putting the you know the the talking
points ready to go for the presentation
doing the research meanwhile a couple
other [ __ ] are standing by eating
snacks drinking [ __ ] diet coke or dr
pepper
letting letting these people do diet
coke and dr pepper are going to start to
send us a cease and desist if we're not
careful
if we're lucky if we're lucky
but you you again you have these people
who actually work on the project do the
work right within this group and there's
a couple people who just kind of stand
by and go whenever i'm not going to
really do it or like oh yeah you know
you know from you know really really
phone it in right and they're just kind
of like saying something half fast
doesn't make any sense and then when it
comes to presenting
to the class the project and they go
through the slides and da da da da
that person
who wasn't willing to do any of the work
is now
talking
right now they're giving
oh i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna read
off this slide right i just gotta say
one thing in front of the teacher to
make it look like i did something and
this is what ron desantis is doing he's
going around taking credit
for the group project that he did not
contribute to
that's what he's doing which is one of
those [ __ ] kids in class who you just
[ __ ] want to punch
because they don't do anything for sure
for sure ron desantis is the is the
[ __ ] that you wanted to you wanted to
kick his
his balls in on the playground and i'm
not theoretically right yeah yeah all
this is all hypothetical theoretical
like when you were a kid in school right
right in school in those projects where
one person
doesn't want to do the work and then
when it comes to presenting in front of
the class
they jut in and say oh well you know
this also and then be like i spoke so i
get credit
that's not how that works texas paul
says he's a coke zero guy oh yeah oh
well yeah yeah i don't even drink coke
and that sounds about right
are you knocking cokes here are you
knocking paul here because no i don't
know i'm saying like i don't
he's saying that he's saying ron
desantis is or he's saying that he is no
he no i think texas paul is is
confirming here that he's a coke zero
a coke zero guy well i didn't mean it
personally i thought it was ronda
sanchez well let me tell you something
maybe we should get texas paul on the
show so texas paul can set the record
straight with with gabe sanchez for
crying out loud the only way he's thing
the only coke i will have
is the mexican bottled coke oh okay
that's the only thing that's the only
thing what
is it because is it bottled there is it
tastes different or well different it's
a different green so actual real sugar
oh okay so it's like the the original
yeah yeah it's not a coca-cola classic
or whatever they rebranded to or coke
new or whatever it's the real [ __ ] but
i'll have it
on tuesdays with my tacos boom i have a
bottle of
so i see what it is so tomorrow that's
the only thing that's only one that's
the only one that'll happen i don't do
any of the others well i i would imagine
uh you know
that ron desantis has probably done his
amount of coke in his day and i'm not
talking about the drink because the gang
is out of his mind which i guess would
make you know pretty close to what you
said earlier you know like he's
you know i guess not the sun like
booger right but he's not he's donald
trump jr
right he's like you know he's like the
terminator he comes back and you're like
oh which version of this right it's like
the upgraded version
from terminator 1 to terminator 2 we're
finding that this guy can now [ __ ]
morph
into this metallic liquid
instead of just being the robotic shell
right well that's true yeah and speaking
of wearing costumes rather it's a trump
costume like ron desantis is trying to
have or uh at
i think it's
sesame place oh god
and we watched this video yeah um so
they end this video here and um it's a
parade
where and these two little girls are
standing here cute as can be right um
and they're watching the parade come
down they're really excited and then one
of the and i'm not sure i think it's zoe
is the character is the actual costume
here
um and it appears that the person in the
costume says no i'm not going to shake
your hand let's watch and then we'll
give our um our commentary on the other
side
you see the character here come up high
five no no and says no no to the kids
and walks away
let's watch it again
so high five to an adult
says no to someone else and then no to
these kids yeah so so i'm not sure
exactly what has happened here now
sesame place has actually put out a
statement on this um now
again i don't know if it makes it better
or worse and i'll bring that up here
here is the uh here's the statement from
sesame place and i'm not going to read
the whole thing but basically what it
says is that
we we value our customers and we stand
with our employees and the inclusive
inclusivity and the equity in all forms
now so they're trying to you know um
really deflect from the racism part here
that it really looks like what has
happened is this character and this uh
cast member as it were i'm not sure is
that what sesame place calls them i know
disney calls them cast members but uh i
don't know and it says employee but i
wouldn't be surprised if disney like
trademarked the phrase that's probably
probably that's probably true those
bastards you know we should probably go
protest with nazi flags outside because
you know we should probably
but but um
in in any uh form here basically the
story that sesame is saying here and i
believe this happened yeah in
philadelphia so there's several of these
of these sesame places
around around the united states i
believe we've actually had a video one
on when john walsh went and he pretended
to be ted cruz
because ted cruz was knocking on sesame
street exactly and i believe that was in
new jersey yeah that one's in new jersey
and here's the thing ted cruz has
he's now continued to knock right he
went after history he went after big
bird again a fictional bird that's like
six years old right then he recently
went after elmo which again a fictional
character that is three years old
a 51 year old person is like nah i'm
gonna [ __ ] attack this fictional
[ __ ]
puppet like that's what it is so here is
the here's the explanation the
performers what they call it
portraying uh rosita the character has
confirmed that the no hand gesture seen
several times in the video was not
directed to any specific person rather
was a response to multiple requests from
someone in the crowd
who asked
for the character or the performer to
hold their child for a photo which is
not permitted is what they
is what the the performer is claiming i
actually don't think that's what's
happening in the video um now rather
that actually happened because
i think we would hear that happening we
hear other people talking around them i
think you would hear
that someone asked those questions if
they were really adamant about it um and
so i actually called bs on this now i'm
not sure what the person was thinking it
definitely it does not look good for
whoever is in that costume
um with what this what this video shows
and i'll play it or i'm going to turn
the sound off but as you watch the
the video here it does not look good
slap no no no no no no no
i mean you know so it doesn't look good
i'm sure here's the thing i am sure
because i don't know when this video was
released this morning but i'm sure that
other people will release other angles
and which it might be more so mailing of
what happened right right and and that
is a possibility here right um
but
for for
better worse sesame place and sesame
street is kind of on their heels this
morning um because i think there's two
ways to approach this either you're a
character that just walks down and waves
right
don't have to deal with ever slapping or
doing a high five but if you're gonna go
through the side
closest to where the people are and
you're gonna high five and do stuff then
you got to commit right like holding a
kid if that's the actual thing that
happened i get it but if you're going
through and you're giving kids high
fives you got to go through all those
kids those kids are there because they
love sesame street and they love the
characters and the excitement to see the
character that they watch on tv in real
life
is incredible
well and even if the intention wasn't uh
through racism for whoever was in the
costume it sure may have made those
little girls feel that way so yeah i i
think i think regardless um of the fact
i think yeah whether intentional or not
yes
they have a long way to go um for that
video and what their protocols are for
certain things whether it was holding um
holding things but how they re how these
characters and performers react again
if they're not supposed to do those
things then they should be walking down
the middle and just waving waiting
waving waving neutral don't interact
with anyone wave at them and give them
the idea just wave yeah bring way way
way great you know a general wave in
this area with a mask on
it covers a wide range of people right
but if you're going up to individual
people and high fiving them and then you
dismiss other people for whatever reason
the person that that gets skipped out on
is going to take it personally right or
could yeah absolutely and especially for
a young child these two little girls who
take it personally be like oh [ __ ] this
is amazing i came here and i saw you
know whatever this character was that i
saw on tv now i get to see them in real
life and you know maybe get a photo or
slap their hand or whatever like that's
one of those kind of like life-changing
like oh my god this is amazing
and hopefully they don't they don't then
take and say like oh i'm not going to
watch a show anymore but you know it
could have a negative effect on the way
that they because really honestly the
sesame street
itself the show its producers for all
these years like this character better
[ __ ] show up to this house well
here's what i'll tell you is like the
last 50 years i mean that really is the
um
i mean it's it's been their mission for
sesame street to really
um you know
send a message to young black girls like
these little girls are so they should
send the message and they have a lot of
making up to do i have some breaking
news here of course it broke in the last
couple hours but dr anthony faunchi
is going to be leaving his role before
the end of the race is going to take
that as a term
yeah so i i mean i i don't know it
doesn't say i don't i don't know if it
says win uh actually i think the
breaking news is that fauci
really wanted to leave oh he wanted to
leave in the last administration well
well i think he really wanted to leave
after president biden took office and
they really started to get vaccines out
there right but but but you know the
dumb [ __ ] like rand paul
and continuing to
spread misinformation and disinformation
about the vaccine and anthony fauci
himself right
didn't allow him to actually exit like
he would want to so that he could get
out of the way of other experts be you
know getting into leadership roles and
taking over for him because he's been
serving he's been serving his country
several administrations right
right it's it's ridiculous and we've
talked we talked about on the show too
which is like
if trump had done his job and not tried
to scapegoat or blame it on anyone else
whether it be berks or or fouchy
no one would ever know fauci's name okay
nobody knew fauci's name
when when ebola was happening
no one
no one because the president went
forward
and he delivered the news and the
updates as a president should instead of
being like oh hey uh can you like again
it's the same thing as ron desantis
you've got one person in the group who
doesn't want to do the work and then
when asked the question during the
presentation they go oh well uh susie's
gonna susie's gonna take this question
she knows all about it and that person's
like what the [ __ ] no no
what whoa whoa why are you throwing me
off right now
that's exactly what trump did
if he had done his job right no one
would have ever known who fought she was
but because of trump fauci gets death
threats he gets uh uh things sent in the
mail like i think there was an uh
potential anthrax scare one time because
there was powder scent
like this guy's just trying to do his
job right he's just trying to help
people out
and these other people these trump
[ __ ] sycophants
are like no
you gotta die you're gonna die for what
you did he's like i'm just trying to
prevent the spread of this [ __ ]
disease like i did the other ones
well speaking of people who were against
fouchy which uh joe rogan has been
apparently he is trending and i think it
may be for this video i'm not sure this
looks like an older video it looks like
his old studio but i may be wrong here
um
mike has here joe rogan calls trump a
man baby
and believe he is on adderall during his
presidency
um he's talking to and
once we go to the other i can i can't
remember if he because they redesigned
the set when he went to austin but once
they go to the other angle to show joe
rogan we'll be able to know okay so so
let's let's listen to what joe rogan
says you know trump rogan and elon musk
and ron desantis are all kind of you
know having these they swim in the same
session drama party drama party but
let's look um
mike sigouria that isn't it and then his
name here this comedian uh which is a
he's a he's a pretty good friend of
rogan's he's a regular guest
on
rogan's show he's got a lot of netflix
um specials he's a very very popular
comedian well i think that's who this is
here but let's listen to the uh him talk
to rogan well about that guy is that you
know i'm saying even when you when you
watch him as president he was full of
[ __ ] energy full of it every day and
they said he slept for like four hours a
night one of those people son adderall
god do you think he's on adderall
yes yep this is current i do be only
because so this is the new set yeah this
is the new one this is the redesigned
set in awesome so this is a more
uh uh well i'm assuming if this clip is
coming out now this is probably pretty
recent
well the other thing too that i'll point
out is tom here and his i said his name
is mike i think but his name is tom uh
tommyer is not as crazy as rogan and
what i mean by that is he's not as loopy
and whack-a-doo and he gets in these
things and rogan does this [ __ ] right so
whoever is sitting in front of rogan
that's who rogan is right it doesn't
matter it doesn't he's not he's he's
definitely he's got a chameleon like
this right right if he's got alex jones
spreading conspiracy alex jones he's
alex jones saying oh yeah it looks like
that's actually pretty true despite he's
got a liberal sitting in front of him
he's really liberal right i mean it just
he he just can't help himself but to go
to go with those the wins and his sails
during his show but let's watch
there were multiple people who used to
work on the apprentice that were like he
was [ __ ]
gassed up for shoots really yeah because
he has trouble reading really he doesn't
he
as if joe rogan's never heard this
before yeah like come on man you haven't
heard this yet this is this is this is
six years in the making here of this
information being out jesus christ no
casler
put it put an nda on his line on the
line for saying a lot of [ __ ] about this
during the apprentice because mark
burnett wouldn't well let's listen he
would he would struggle to read prompter
or script when he was just uh let's say
sober
so they would give him that and he would
dial in more on reading because he gets
he gets very bored they said you know
he would get bored at the c.i.a briefing
in the mornings he was like i don't want
to read that there's a daily briefing
you get as president he's like you
[ __ ] read it and then tell me and if
it's boring so they would have to make
it more engaging for him because he
would i heard that they would put his
name in briefings multiple times to keep
him interested and then
kushner you know his son-in-law
said that he came up with a formula
uh to keep him engaged
yes because you know he obviously was
close to him and knew him well and the
formula was i love how rogan hasn't
heard any of this stuff yeah like he's
supposed to be
sort of expert and he talks about this
[ __ ] like he knows what he's talking
about and this is simple [ __ ] that we've
known for years we've known this
reporting
for years this isn't new knowledge and
it's almost like rogan is just
it's almost like he's being introduced
to running water here yeah
whoa whoa whoa i'm waking up right now
you know like i just took the red pill
and i've learned so much about trump
yeah again like this is the same guy who
was like hey how do we nuke a hurricane
can we nuke a hurricane is that possible
can we do that that's the thing no yes
okay cool more diet coke like this is
the guy it should be not be surprising
but i think these stories have already
come out too where it's
uh making him feel important right
knowing that he wouldn't be you know he
wasn't interested in the briefings and
when people be like oh did you read that
thing and you're like oh no we never got
to it today and it's like you know who
you have one job on you know we should
have on we should have on jessica denson
she she's the indian trump killer and
she worked um with the 2016 trump
campaign we should have her on and see
if there's actual truth to that because
i know i know personally talking to her
she has actually sat next to trump and
had to do presentations to him way back
when um of course you know she worked
her way at him out of this maca delusion
and realized the truth about trump and
who he was and what he was and actually
fought against and been the only person
to beat his campaign's nda at this point
um but maybe we should have iran to talk
about that let's finish what this joe
rogan
how
how how astounded he is by news that is
three years old
um
like
two good one bad so if they were gonna
give him bad news they could go you
start with some good news
so they go this is going well
everybody's thrilled with you about this
here's a bad thing
also people love you for this
so that's how you that's how they would
tell them bad news it's santa we
couldn't just go here's a bunch of
badges of course yeah he's a man baby
he's a [ __ ] toddler
yeah he's a toddler
oh it's funny now you laugh now joe you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] here's the thing
that strategy is not a jared kushner
thing they
when you go to like um
pta has classes that you take for like
parenting classes and stuff and uh me
and my wife have actually attended some
of them that's actually [ __ ] they teach
you yeah to handle it's not a jared co
chair
that's just that's a good question
right well jared kushner didn't come up
with that idea that's actually one way
to disarm a a a a child who has
behavioral problems right that's one way
to disarm them is to give them a good
piece of thing a bad piece of thing a
good piece of thing right to try to keep
their mind working towards good things
well the only thing that can stop bad
news tony is good news well that is true
but again
this is it's a very common practice in
business when you're like oh i gotta
deliver this bad news to a client right
how do i how do i cushion some good
sugar coat it you know
good news first bad news like
if you had a if you you know if you have
a partner would you go to the partner
immediately the bad news
right you would try to soften the blow
whatever it might be right to be like so
i threw that thing out and it's like but
you start with
here are some flowers i love you you're
amazing
also i want to take you out for dinner
it's like it's one of those things it's
common doesn't know that this happened
though how does he not know that this
happened it's because he's a [ __ ]
bonehead right
now everyone i'm one i want to reiterate
again this thursday we are going to have
a hearing it is going to be in prime
time so we're going to have two episodes
you're going to get to see me all day
that day thursday
you're going to see i'm getting it right
i am going to i'm going to i haven't
done it yet but i'm going to make a bowl
of popcorn this one good good so you're
going to see us at a regular time noon
eastern
11 central nine pacific as you do every
single weekday monday through friday on
youtube twitter twitch don't forget to
follow us here on youtube um
you have to follow us here on youtube to
get into the chat texas paul is here
today
for getting a chat maybe we should paul
on tomorrow to give us an update from
texas what do you think i think i think
we'll do that i think we'll do it we'll
have paul on to give us an update from
texas and then on thursday don't forget
to miss uh texas paul on the panel
because we will have coverage from the
behind us touch youtube channel so go
follow um on minus touch youtube channel
the minus touch network we will bring
you
a live coverage of the hearing an hour
before during the break and after we
will have special commentary from the
likes of a midas mighty like texas paul
also some other panel great panelists
are coming back i'm sure to to talk to
us jessica jensen being one of them um
maybe popock from legal af or karen
agnitholo from legal or maybe the
brothers the brothers the mizellas bros
yeah i think i think we can have it's
gonna be it's gonna be a party i think
it will be i think it will be so stay
tuned go follow uh again go to the
youtube chat mind as touch network the
youtube channel the link is there it is
there right now and go follow us on
twitter at tonymichaelspod you can also
find the link there
for the hearing and set your reminder
you're not going to want to miss it and
until tomorrow at noon eastern 11
central as we do every single weekday
here surf's up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking